all right aw thank you um hi
everyone I need to apologize if my uh if
I start to draw it's probably the jet
lag and the fact that I have an
incredibly porous pet um I only need to
stand next to someone who speaks
differently in my accent Go funny um uh
this's going make an annoying noise I
may take it off later um so this is kind
of an introduction of of of me to to
this program what I want to talk about
is is American content in Australia and
the the way in which it's made domestic
by The Branding strategies uh and the
scheduling strategies of uh Australian
networks I'm going to truncate some of
the things that I want to say to try and
get to the end a little bit more rapidly
because a lot of the things that uh that
I a lot of the challenges I think that
Australian networks are facing in the
current ER reflect um back Upon A lot of
the things that we've already heard in
the thus far um so that's where we're
going oh this is an old television set
from Australia Australia used to have a
television manufacturing industry um
back in 1956 there a company called ASA
and I'll talk about them a little bit
later and they used to make televisions
um and this isn't one of their this is
an awa set um but this is an old
Australian
television bringing things together okay
um so as I said I look at the role of
American content plays on Australian
television um and look at the way in
which it's localized because in many
respects
uh lots of American content is uh
natural they use the eagil bunns because
natural is one of those contested dirty
terms um and I'm going to apply it uh
kind of judiciously um across this this
presentation and then I'll look at at at
the kind of challenges that are faced by
the networks but I want to start by
talking about Katie hols um who I
realize she's now perhaps a little bit
crazy but time and and this is work that
that um there's based on my PhD pis at
the time Katy HS was a principal
motivator for me writing a
PhD I wrote my PhD about Dawson's Creek
um and specifically about about young
people and the representation of young
people on aonian television and so Katy
Holmes was was important to me partly
because she's attractive and and a kind
of wholesome team staff and if anything
she probably shows my own bias towards
seemingly intelligent brunettes um more
than anything else but for a core period
throughout the 90s um Dawson Creek was a
core site where youth could be seen on
Australian television um and this is I
don't know how well you can see this
this is about 10 years or 12 years in
austral television history and these are
all of the programs that represented
youth uh in the 10 year 12E period that
I worked at um when I was doing my
thesis um these dark ones in I can find
my
poter these dark ones in dark blue are
these blue ones in dark blue are all of
the American programs all the American
teen dramas that represented young
people on Australian telion and you'll
see that most of them are the
exceptional um or quite successful
iterations of uh the the genre
um against uh these kind of American
programs we have a series of uh domestic
programs but there's a distinction here
this represents four of the networks I'm
going talk in a minute about the
Australian telion environment um but
what we see are the FL of the networks
and the important thing about this table
is to point out that all of the American
content predominantly screens on the
commercial networks um and all of the
domestic content predominantly in terms
of representing young people screens on
um the public broadcaster and that is
kind of important for the things that
I'm about to say so I might stop
justifying things and get
on so my thesis was about these two
programs okay on the right we have dors
Creek I'm going to presume now that
people are familiar with Dawson's Creek
and this ridiculous uh incredibly post
ironic and post modern Homespun fantasy
tale about a stalker um his giant
forehead and he's lovely B next door on
the other side we have heartbreak high
now heartbreak high was was a really
really really really interesting
Australian program was based on a film
um called the heartre kid and it was a
spin-off and it was a teen drama was
about kids in like this guy Urban High
School in syney it was commissioned by
Channel 10 uh and 10 is a youth specific
broadcaster in Australia lasted about 12
months on channel 10 before it was
shunted uh to 11:00 and then passed off
to the ABC it lasted 8 years on the ABC
now that may not mean much to you except
our public broadcaster doesn't have the
money to produce content so hre high was
an international co-production that uh
by the end of its life was being really
holy funded by the BBC uh French uh
production company a German production
company and a smattering of money coming
from 18 other countries including places
like Israel and Tanzania and stuff
anyway so these were the two programs
that I was looking at uh this one
because it represented for a point the
the genre that represented youth on
Australian television and this one
because it was a domestic program that
couldn't manage to be successful despite
the fact that it gave off a a an
accurate and quite compelling of
Australian youthfulness and what this
points to to a certain extent is the
fact that American content assumes this
natural place on Australian television
in certain instances and that's what I
want to talk about Australia um the
Australian television network I just
want a brief overview um we have a jeal
system that is apparently unique in the
world we have two publicly funded
broadcasters the ABC and the SBS um the
SBS I'm I'm not going to talk about it's
a multicultural channel is fantastic
it's part publicly funded and part
commercial funded the other three
channels uh on on Australian television
are
commercial uh the invention of
Television uh in Australia was a postwar
invention uh it came in in 56 um and we
imported the public broadcasting from
the BBC and the commercial model from
the US and that distinction has remained
for a long time in that uh in addition
to producing domestic content and there
is a requirement that all stations prod
domestic content the public broadcaster
generally Imports programs from VC and
the commercial broadcasters generally
import programs from the US um and these
are some figures they're not mine
they're from the AFC the Australian film
commission which does this Progressive
update um of what Australians are
producing and and watching um and so
what we can see is that by the time we
get to 2003 and 2004 we've got 53
stations and they're linked together
into five National networks and the
national network that that I'll talk
about when I talk about channels because
they generally dictate program a lot
like the affiliate system here um
there's less autonomy um and what we're
importing is um $26.7 Million worth of
Drama um and only $104 Million worth of
other programming so the largest bulk of
our import is
drama um and you can see that the
expenditure on Australian drama is only
115 million
so we're importing kind of roughly twice
what we're
spending um the majority of the content
that is imported the drama content
screens during prime time so whil the
networks are required to screen uh
55% of Australian content during prime
time in order to maintain their licenses
the bulk of the content that they import
is drama and it screams during prime
time so what the Australian networks
produced a little bit of drama and a lot
of Lifestyle programming um we buy a lot
of
formats like endol sells us a whole
bunch of things we have Idol we have big
brother for a time we had Survivor but
it's really
bad like they sent people to the West
Coast um Australia is a big country it's
a giant Island as it is um but what they
do was take a bunch of City size and
send them kind of a couple hours north
of Perth which is which is the Western
most point in the world or something um
but they were all columnists were sh how
does that work as a Survivor concept
anyway it tanked and and now we have the
American Survivor and it does
particularly well um the point of the
point of this is is to point out
that for the drama programming 29.1% of
the total broadcast hours are drama
programming but only 25% of the total
broadcast hours are Australian drama
programming
these are the um are the top 40 programs
uh for 2004 and what you see is is that
despite the fact that prime time is
dominated by imported programs
particularly from 8:30 onwards often
you'll get two episodes of CSI back to
back um 8:30 through 10:30 um the top
programs are still predominantly
Australian because uh what sales or what
scores in the ratings are Live Events so
it's often sporting events ID
particularly well in 2004 it was only 2
years earlier that a non-sporting
program was the was the top program in
the country and so in terms of top
programs uh the amount of drama that we
import is severely underrepresented so
trying I'm not trying to suggest that
the Australian broadcasting environment
is dominated by employed content or that
domestic content doesn't score well with
viewers it
does but if we look at the top dramas
for 2004 we see that they are
predominant imported now that's not
surprising given the amount of drama
that we import my whole point is that
this is not a problem in
Australia um and this is just a little
rough to show you the the spend the top
is the export spend in millions and
these are all Australian figures so I
think one to get the American spent um
but predominantly we're importing close
to 300 million from the USA um and
probably
75 million from the UK and some from
elsewhere now oh that's one going in a
minute um and so what I what I think
happens here is that all of this
imported program is made to cohere to
domestic
Logics uh American content has always
had a very very natural place on
Australian television when television
was introduced in in um 1956 there was
one of the first programs was by ASA who
was making sets it was called This is
television uh and it screened on the
16th of September uh in Sydney 1956 and
it was basically uh a half hour
promotional wheel for television itself
um the first half was about how
television was going to be producing
television the physical sets was going
to be a substantial postwar industry and
Australia was going to be a world leader
in producing sets that was going to
revitalize our economy and all there's
this wonderful footage I tried to bring
it with me but
custom um there's this this wonderful
footage of all of these postwar women
and their po labor just being moved from
making bullets and stuff to assembling
boxes and putting exciting stuff in the
boxes and we still export CF shoes so
industry yeah um but the other half of
this year's television talked about the
fact that television would bring us a
whole new world right W to your home
television offered a range of carefully
selected shows in every category screen
at the most suitable time for the
particular audience
including for the whole family the
extremely popular Leave it to
Beaver award-winning detective series
draget from the master of suspense
Alfred Hitchcock
Presents and comedy and laugh for
everyone such as the Burns and Allen
Show and all the kids enjoy all the
stars of the cartoon world such as rough
and ready basically television was
imported to Australia as as an American
commodity as it was um there was uh some
um mention made of the fact that they
would also bring TOP English and
domestic Stars into your home but
generally the new world that television
would offer um was one that would bring
a wonderful world of entertainment from
outside into Australia the development
of the domestic Market was kind of a
secondary thought um and this is the
introduction of this is School SCH kids
in in early 60s in country Australia
being told how to use u a
television um now the presence of
American content on in Australia enabled
us very quickly to start television we
didn't have to go through the rhma of of
working out how to make it
ourselves um we had these wonderful
models but we also had a whole lot of
content so from the word go we had like
a six or an 8 hour schedule um within
the space of uh of about 8 or 10 years
we had a a close to a 24-hour schedule
because we had a whole lot of content um
Australian programmers talk with some
pride about the fact that we can import
um content we we get the best television
in the world because the fact that we
speak English means that we can import
from the two largest english- speaking
markets despite this American television
still gets blamed despite the fact that
American television is a natural part of
the Australian television experience it
still gets blamed for destroying our
kids um there's there's a whole lot of
this that happens in Australia and it's
a pathology about who we are and it's a
pathology about technology so no one
take it personally because no one
actually knows uh the people and this is
this is from a guy called Walter pening
who wrote in um a letter to the editor
in a Sydney paper after the kindergarten
down the road implemented a buddy
program and he decided that he should
write a letter
the telegraph decided that it should
publish it um because apparently we've
never had a buddy in Australia and I
understand that semantics are important
but I don't think they're this important
um but of course what I want to point
out here is the fact that what's
destroying our domestic culture what's
replacing our domestic culture is the
fact that kids are watching too much
American television Walter pending is
probably in the
60s uh this letter is from 2002
so he was probably alive when television
was introduced to this country and he
was probably particularly young in the
50 years that television has been in
Australia it hasn't managed to destroy
his cultural identity uh even though
it's been prod American so what I want
to point out is that this fear of
Americanization is is connected
generally to our sense of national
identity or the way that it's
articulated to the world it's just a
whipping
dog
anyway so American content exists in
Australia because uh or functions in
Australia not because we understand
inherently um the Logics of America and
not because we are in some way little
Americans despite what some people like
to think it works because it is made
domestic by a whole range of strategies
um employed by the domestic broadcasters
to make the content profitable to make
their business Prof and particularly
important here is continuity and
branding material some of my favorite
programming matter refer to as ID this
is the television that isn't there it's
the television that papers over the gaps
when the medium sticks through between
programming and advertising it's the ads
for television and for television
networks and it's where we get
articulated the idea of the audience
that the network is drawing uh it serves
a jeel purpose and it advertises what's
coming up but it also uh demonstrates uh
range of responses for Australian
viewers um to kind of show how they can
participate in the audience uh that the
network is offering it's all about
creating a
community uh and so this is this is a t
just about 2001 um there is a
seamlessness uh in the way in which
American content exists on Australian
television um frasia was incredibly
incredibly incredibly successful we had
a program called sale of the centc is an
American format I think I know that it's
here anyway um and after many many many
years it was revitalized as sale of the
new century and it lasted about a week
before it was taken off and it was
replaced with frasia um and frasia was
just a bit of filler program that was
pulled out of the arivs um that uh the
Australian networks had not paid very
much money for nine had not paid very
much money for and they were just going
to slap it in fill the Gap frasia did
better figures than anything else that n
had ever put in the 7:00 slot and so it
sat in the slot for for close to 4 years
but we we move seamlessly from the
national news which is is before frasia
to frasia to getaway which is a lifesty
program people go to the places and get
on those paring things um then into er
uh and then into the Footy Show uh and
the Footy Show is about uh uh where this
is from the Footy Show is um about one
of the national codes NRL uh it's a bit
like rugby um there is no
armor Chase pig skin they beat each
other up uh and the Footy Show is
commentary about footy by a bunch of BLS
who like to bloke it up so it's it's
actually an incredibly Australian
program it plays with a lot of the
discourses about Australian masculinity
and this this was a fairly successful
lineup um channel one is the preeminent
broadcaster um they're certainly the
ratings winner uh and this lineup won
them I think it was Thursday nights um
for about 12
months now the reason or or the way in
which these uh imported programs are
made domestic I think is demonstrated
particularly by the Quant I want to show
you just a couple of things now um to
try and explain the way that that
American telion functions so I can get
on to what are some of the challenges
Australian face um this is from 995 when
er was just coming to Australia it
should work
hopefully
all
right
okay what n did was stitch together a
montage of
um of their their branding positions
over the
years
and they played it over the the theme
song and then gave us a whole bunch of
title slides for uh domestic programs I
hope that some of this looks familiar
because a lot of them are in formats and
there's actually a trade in continuity
material Nine's still the one position
uh I think was first uh CVS position uh
and nine purchased it or pinched it
really
um and so what we get are a lot of the
common themes of uh Australian
broadcasting it starts with um the the
nine balls which is they fam they
dropped now but were a really quite
prominent identifier for nine was the
nine new Mull and these nine balls and
so it starts with that and then uh we
get an image of the nation and
television in Australia is is often
associated with nationalist we are uh
quite a small nation that is brought
together uh by the fact that we have
that we have television and then played
over the uh soundtrack we get a whole
bunch of Australian programs and then
finally end up with
the the point is that nine draws this
line of equivalence between all of its
programs that's produced itself between
the network and between its imported
programming American drama does well in
Australia because it's high concept it's
high budget and it's generally fairly
attract
now certain dramas sink and certain
dramas swim and that has to do with the
vagaries of the Australian Market CSI
does well Law and Order does
well I'm trying to think of something
that's Sun now Los vas
sunk um uh Chicago Hope sunk but I think
it's sunk here as well ER did well um
commanderin-chief
sunk
Stone
Boston is it when it came out it was
like everyone was like Jina
Davis and then no like um L does well
but it's it's eing off which I think is
doing here as well Desperate Housewives
again did well but it's sustaining
itself not on its uh on its
innovativeness but on the fact that on
soap now but anyway uh High concept
American drama function in Australia
almost as a Baseline and that's why we
have
the on American content introduced from
the start to start the Australian
Network the networks has always existed
as television it's reliable some of it's
going to be crap but generally it is
television and so what nine does in that
promo is draw this line between what we
understand quality to be namely high
content American drama
all of their domestic programs and the
network themselves they draw this
equivalence to say all of this is
actually all of this reflects upon each
other on each other and it is quality
Nine's branding position trades on the
fact that it is the ratings winner um
and it has up until quite recently um
for about 10 or 12 years even a bit
longer um being the number one uh annual
n rating network uh in the country even
though it doesn't do so well in the
markets so nine says we offer you as
Australian viewers quality and all of
this program equals quality the
distinctions uh that are domestic or
International are are kind of written
off along the
way um and so that's kind of one of the
ways in which in which American is made
to work in the Australian Market the
other way is by
forgoing uh forgoing images of the
nation Al together and instead selling
in the community um I talked before
about and this is this brings us all
back to Katie Holmes and why I wasn't
just putting her up there because I
think she's cute um uh the third
commercial broadcas in the country is
called the 10 Network the 1980s it went
bust as did most of the networks
commercial networks in austral too much
Capital ideas um it went bust it was
bought by Ken West which is a Canadian
company owned by the late easa um and it
was bought by came in 1991 without a
receivership you can't own a foreign
owner cannot own television station or a
media company in Australia uh and so the
contract that was drawn up to establish
holding companies so that can West could
maintain a voting right in 10 is a
fantastic piece of legislation that
lawyers work themselves over anyway 10
became Successful by targeting a youth
audience okay it said what going to do
is Target 16 to 39 and so they premiered
this strategy with
Simpsons
cops BS those were their three standout
programs they then added to that lineup
um things like SF um and no place they
didn't produce a whole lot of content or
they didn't produce a whole lot of
domestic content that was successful
most of their dramas would run a b to
season see Australian networks have to
produce it and they have to screen it
doesn't have to do particularly well
they don't have to renew it for another
season um and so for a long time they
didn't actually produce a whole lot of
successful domestic
content what ten did was move away or
dislocate itself from the ideas of
nationalism that have been important to
Australian ran positions and instead
they constructed
themselves the
network as the location where
youthfulness could be accessed that you
is basically inventor concept and I'm
calling it youthfulness because it is
not Youth and youth is a fallacy anyway
but it is not you Law and Order does
very well on channel 10 at 1 Point scre
five or six times a week what is
youthful about Law and Order certainly
not much you know was cool um so what T
did was create this discursive
environment where youthfulness was
practiced and everything in this
environment could count as
youthful they did this by moving away
from kind of concrete images um and
instead creating this kind of no
space what do you want to
be this is actually one of my favorite
ever positions um it's it's from 2003 a
long running series that t run um but
this is when they started to produce
domestic PR actually being quite
successful they distinguish themselves
from other networks by not selling the
product or the program but instead
selling the lifestyle and it's
traditional youth marketing but 10
corded it to television and often their
promos would not feature any programming
at all they just talk about all of the
things that Tim was offering people what
they do is make youth um a referred
sorry make youth a signifier that has no
Bas referred so there is no concrete
thing that is youth if you want to be
youthful and who doesn't all you have to
do is come in watch 10's
programing what this managed to do is
create an environment where Niche
economics could be successful so they
took the large pie of Australian
television and said we're not going to
bother competing with the other two
commercial networks for all people cuz
we're going to lose anyway instead we're
going to take 16 to 39 and if we win 16
to 39 then we won for the week and
actually didn't win 16 to 39 very often
until 2001 but they told everyone that
they did win and they picked up
wonderful fallacy of ratings is that
like any statistics you can pick them up
and make them say whatever you want so
they pick up the instances where they
did win what this did but was make uh
created an economic environment where
programs that wouldn't survive
on uh the broad channels could be
incredibly popular and so we end up in
an environment where Dawson's Creek is a
success in a market that cannot support
um programs that don't score large
figures nine through a uh an output deal
acquired the OC in 2003 they premiered
as this kickass new youth program nine
targets a very broad 16 to 54 more
people B and female market so they
premiered the OC as this kickass new
team drama they put it on at 8:30 one
night lasted two episodes before it
tanked they sold the rights to
10 so nine still making money out of it
but then I have to screen it they sold
the rights to 10 10 premiered it and it
became the hit of
2005 This Is How They launched
it
this one's a
quick some shows are just made for
you
[Music]
okay so what what ten did is that they
set up this equivalency between the
viewer at home and the network and
whereas in Nine's promo before the
equivalency was set up between the
network and see that little map of
Australia between the network and the
nation 10 chooses not to think beyond
the network itself and so they say we as
Channel 10 are like you the viewer at
home this is the important thing about
10's strategy
ch ch um they have a
logo and while they were establishing
this strategy what they used to do was
play with the logo a lot in their uh in
their idence and they often in title
cards running between programs whack the
program that was coming up in the logo
it was this funneling
device
that says view um so what Tim would do
is say we are a
window for you the viewer to access the
wider world of youth culture by the time
we get to the OC T has done away with
the idea of them being a window at all
they are the site where youth culture
exists what this does is strip away the
ideas of nationalism okay in this
model I don't know that's right any in
in in in the Lo the window logo is
window model viewers are still located
in Australia and looking out to the
world in the latter model there is no
National distinctions and content that
is appropriate for you the viewer is
here on
10 now I'm actually going somewhere with
all of this and it's not just a journey
for Australian
television the point is that American
content exists as a profitable element
on Australian television however Supply
outstrips
demand I don't want to say we have been
taught to like American content but
there are a whole bunch of viewers in
Australia who do like a whole bunch of
programs but not enough other viewers
like to keep them on television it's a
problem for viewers
everywhere um programs like The West
Wing and the Gilmore Girls are two of my
favorite examples because they're both
in AUST in 6 they're both in all three
of them in Australia inspired quite
passionate followings but they were on
nine and none of them could draw a
market share to justify their place on
the schedule so the westl famously was
shed around shed around and then sold to
the public broadcaster in speed under
used to do three or four weeks at 11:30
at night before it was preempted uh for
a couple of weeks without notice in 2004
the hot question on the Australian
interwebs was when is 6 feet under
coming back the answer December
2006 didn't even come back in's time
what the problem
here
Pirates what we've done is or what's
happened is that for the first time
actually this
model which doesn't refer to 10 at
all this model of distribution in
Australia is is is no longer the only
model there is an alternative for a long
time the alternative has been DVD
release okay and it was and there was
quite a bit of precence right about how
it was possible to uh nearly nearly keep
up um with the West here if you knew
people in the states who could sell send
you the DVD um the other story I before
is that for a long time we could use
Amazon if we didn't have an American
Credit Card Amazon resolved that problem
very Sly um and so viewers who are
promised something by the network and
who don't get it now have the option to
go uh to go
elsewhere um and I think that this is a
fundamental problem uh in a nation that
relies so much
on imported content um but doesn't have
the capacity to screen it there's a
whole other discussion here about the
opportunities for multi channeling and
stuff that I just I don't have time for
today but I want to just this this is
kind of my proposition and this sums up
I I think in this we can see a lot of
the things that that been talked about
here um particularly in stuff yesterday
about about fan subing um and discussion
this morning um about entertainment um
and also even the last two papers about
Community formation Stu television works
as a closed expert system okay and I'm
actually this is not mine I'm cting this
from John Harley by sorry this is this
is leiger by John Harley um so no want
to quote me on this I'll put
some um television is a closed expert
system you take creative Innovative
professionals and you remove them from
consumers you put them in an environment
where they can be creative if you work
on friends it's somewhere you can swear
and tell dirty jokes um but you lock
them up a way so that they can be C they
generate a whole bunch of ideas that are
then sifted through trial out on test
markets and eventually standardized as a
format that format is then pop down the
line to Consumers and consumption
becomes a behavioral response we offer
you something that is supposed to make
you listen or make you look or make you
watch and the system works if we give it
to and you
watch now in Australia there are a whole
bunch of people who prepared to watch
but they can't get the content they've
been promised the content but it's no
longer
around and I'm
not there are a whole bunch of other
politics to that that I'm I'm not doing
Justice to now that I accept exist the
alternative I think for Australian
networks and I think perhaps more
broadly is to move what's called move to
what's called an open Innovation and
this is one where rather than than just
piping the content down the line to the
viewer the viewer is offered
opportunities to pipe content back up
the line it's about not only creating a
community for viewers to participate in
but being a participant in that
Community
yourself um what what this does is not
only provide viewers with a space uh to
actually contribute but also reward them
for
contribution um and the solution to that
problem is just letting go a little bit
and
not calling everyone a pirate but
accepting that being a member of a
community has benefits that flow both
ways um that's actually where I'm I'm
going to conclude now um I hope that
some of some of this has been kind of
relevant I realized that that the
American system is vastly different and
I feel a little bit like Raymond
Williams Because when I got here the
other night there was a jarring moment
where I couldn't work out whether I was
watching a program or whether I was
watching advertising and I thought I was
kind of on Fame with with the commercial
system um but in Australia we have these
they do these little these little brake
bumpers and they love them um and they
do them a whole lot so that whenever you
go a break it's announced as a bre um
and I actually thought that was an
American thing but I realized now I
think it's a British thing I know that I
saw MTV do some the other night but the
transition is so seamless that I just it
just was a little bit juring um so I'm
Happ type questions um if anyone has any
fruit I'm happy to stand in the front so
you can with it now um but that's where
I'm going to
[Applause]
finish and
question understanding when you look
back at and you watch what shows you
are
segment
audience yeah yeah um uh no um the pro I
I for television academic I only watched
the public broadcaster if I was 12 um
not because my parents were strict just
because I like Dr um and it was on the
public broadcaster so when I when I
think back to the program that I enjoyed
as a boy
um uh is segmented by age and there is a
a my my recollection is a real a quite
segmented one that that had periods I
know that up until I was I was 12 or or
or even a little bit older um the
programs that I liked were smattering um
but predominantly British and Australian
Australia produces some of the world co-
produces some of the world's best
children drama and it's actually
something quite D me but when I was a
lad there was there were good options in
terms of children's drama so programs
that were specifically relevant to my
age there's a tendency in young people
to uh watch up or view up um and there's
a a component of my thesis involved
going and discussing with some kind of
14 to 17 year olds what they thought of
television and what they thought of
Youth programming and the
representations of Youth and what we see
with young people particularly young
boys is that they're aspirational
viewers young girls do as well so when
you are 14 you want to watch programs
about people who are a bit older than
you and when you are 16 you want to
watch um when you're a young lad you may
not necessarily be interested in
children's drama say at 12 14 but you're
more interested in uh you know C
programs and and those sorts of things
so there's an aspirational component uh
to viewing there can you just just D I
realized actually answer question so can
you just just ask me
again let me in my head I'm actually
trying to address what you asked
justs
Australian what your sweet spot yeah at
at at my age The Sweet Spot is uh
Quality quality drama um with a with a
big queue and a qualifier underneath it
um and sporting programs uh one of the I
got an email last night from someone at
home telling me that there's actually in
Boston quite a large Australian
um uh expat community and apparently is
possible to get the football here um and
so as a viewer coming from Australia
moving internationally I feel quite
comfortable moving particularly here to
environment where with Contin is
American because if it's not the
programs it's certainly the form that I
feel familiar with since we got cable in
1995 we have the Cartoon Network now but
we also have a a a fox Ono called Fox8
that screens uh a whole lot of kind of
teen drama and and stuff um get Lifetime
and those sorts of things so as a viewer
coming here I I'm certainly looking for
the form rather than the content itself
that doesn't answer your question but
I'm just I'm having a little bit trouble
giving I the answer is you mind kind of
comment on observation because I think
one of the interesting things about this
it's all about resources and funding and
you know me being from Ireland the same
kind of situation and you look at
programming here for example because the
money is behind it the the funding the
programming is done high quality program
and sent out now the funny thing is then
you ask yourself is culture influencing
culture so American culture influencing
other cultures um and it's funny because
then there's stereotyping of culture and
I'll give you an example importing of
programming in here so for example if
you go on PBS and you look at Irish
programming Unfortunately they only they
only screen it in St Patrick's week you
know or Mar and it's always you know
it's either River
it's what is all this stuff is like 20
years old and and you can you can take
the same thing as Benny Hill any any
subpec Englishman who looks at it's
stereotyp FY power Ben Benny Hill people
don't watch that there you know that's
something that's that's years ago so
people look look at it that way and the
other interesting thing from an American
programming standpoint is that if they
see something that is is a good property
they'll take it themselves and change it
the office is a prim example you know
look at the office in the UK and then
look it over here and they change it
there are some people who are Pur americ
only watch the the real office versus
the American they did the same with cou
um I think which they took from the UK
and remade
here I think they actually quite with
the office um and and i' S a bit of at
home and bit on the plane and and you
know the translation Works um because
they took the form rather than the
content um and they to make the form
domestically relevant and that's sort of
the same the same thing we don't do
sitcoms in Australia we have a tradition
of doing patic sitcoms partly because
the form uh and the cand after I think
we accept as being a little American and
that's not to suggest that it comes with
uh some the transport some sort of
cultural values but rather we expect to
see Americans in sitcoms behaving in
particular ways and we accept that there
is a critical distance between us as
viewers and that content such that it
exists off in the television ether
whereas domestic drama suffers from the
weight of representation so if it and
this was the problem with heartbreak
High here and I think white do quite
well internationally but here when I say
here I'm in Australia I'm in Australia
right now cover is that hre high okay
Dawson's Creek paints this wonderful
stalk of fancy about you know Star Cross
lovers and and kind of fatalism as hre
high was about gry Urban youthfulness
you're a young person and they say this
is what being a young person in
Australia is like today and you go no
it's not then resing the critical
distance between you and the program is
quite is quite different is quite
difficult for some Australian viewers
insurmountable whereas the distance
between Australian viewers and an
American sit home actually adds to part
of uh the relationship that develop it
is a flly
fancy okay just I'm trying to think of
other explanatory pars I was wondering
about the culture of self-replication
that seems so Australian but I mean
maybe more what I'm curious about
because I just finished a fiveyear study
in Europe of TV and identity problematic
was of course Very Central to it um at
least in a lot of European settings I'll
think the dut in particular were it's
the same Dynamic American programming
out rates the local and yet their
mandates to produce local there I think
one of the key reasons is when you talk
to people about what how they
characterize high production values U
slightly more Universal themes when
they're finding with the local stuff but
the thing that leaps out for most of
them both in terms of cinematic
Hollywood production and production is
pacing and why it's pacing is because
they pluck the ads out yeah and put them
they bumper them so the front end and
the back end havee ad chunks and no ads
in between so to an American viewer use
the ads you know four five times it's
the narrative is a roller coaster it's
not a threea structure five or sixa
structure when they see it there
it's Nar
has compared to Stu
commercial networks run like commercial
was here actually the US system so the
programs uh they just SL ads into the ad
SLS every ad SL
every um every every is Spill there and
it runs actually I hav been able when I
was I had this house with the girl with
sugar and we used to watch uh uh Law and
Order like was going out of
fashion study that was what we did um
and so I have been able since to watch
an episode of Law and Order but I'm
recognizing the the cases so I think
before I go home I'm to sit and watch
one and see if it is the same because my
understanding of is that they just put
ads in exactly the same slots um
comparatively there was a little bit of
thought for a Time some discussion about
the fact that Australian content was
differently and and the key distinction
was that the stories were simpler or
that they unfolded at a different pace
even though they they were still fit in
the same ad slots the trick with
domestic content but is that if it is
good it raed and so Channel 10 in 2001
premiered a program called The Secret
Life Of Us which did Five Seasons about
six young people living in Sydney and it
was actually really really really really
good television an Out rated competing
American content because it was it was
well paced it it f things um it's the
same with M Cloud's daughters which I
believe is being imported here as a
girls in the bush Aon Williams riding
horses working on a ranch stuff doing
for themselves sisters and stuff um and
it's actually a lot faster than than the
competing cop drama which is a country C
program called Blue Hills um and so I
think that pacing is an issue but the
programs are kind of preserv as I as I
here um I'm Canadian and and I have I
recognize lot some of what you were
saying um and I wondered if somebody
asked Martin sh an American interviewer
asked Martin sh why so many comedians in
the states were Canadian yeah and his
answer was well you grew up watching TV
I grew up watching American TV so St to
suggest is this slight kind of distance
and sometimes it's critical distance
Capital C sometimes it's critical lower
case sometimes it's just distance and I
wondered if that difference between
fullon engagement and that slight remove
is the difference between Channel 9
engagement and channel 10 engagement yes
I think it's why Channel 10 mons is
what's been a very successful tagline
which is
seriously Channel 10 employs uh
uh encourage Their audience to be
playful uh the little trailer before has
a whole a whole bunch of phrases that
supposed to sum up the values you as a
viewer should have and it's things like
being happy being strong being cheering
Che it's playfulness it's irony and
there is uh uh there is a step away that
they encourage you to take from some of
the program particularly when programs
like pumped screen on channel 10 and the
whole thing is just a shog supposed to
it did it did arrive but you as the
viewer are not supposed to take
particularly seriously and 10 has has
really employed seriously and it's about
six or eight year as a an ironic
statement for its viewers to adopt so I
I think that you're right more questions
or other
questions you know so I was just com
comment pick up on your that was very
interesting because I think there is
that that the ability of of other
cultures to look at other other cult
program distance themselves especially
with you know uh post 911 when a lot of
people like within Ireland were looking
at American programming and all this
kind of stuff they where they could a
certain Affinity to the individuals but
you know there were part of them where
they felt they might be somewhat
American part of American cure but not
part of the American politics or IDE and
all that which it a completely other
kind of road to go down but I supp the
point I want to finish on is that is
that I think that there is a a common
understanding and that and that you can
um but that that there's not a trade in
cultural values which is the way that
the American Australian relationship
certainly has
long